Well, you know, you're a survivor, because you are there.
Well, obviously my contemporaries
who committed these atrocities are dreadful
but I'm concerned that sometimes I think
what I would have been, if I hadn't been Jewish.
Would I have been a Nazi?
And I probably would.
You know, it's very difficult for a 12, 13, 14 year old
to resist the temptations
the Nazis offered for kids of that age.
Uniforms, camp fires,
learning to shoot rifles,
things like that, as they did in the Hitler Youth.
And it's very, very difficult for a kid of that age
to resist that temptation
and not be part of the crowd.
It's a warning I suppose to people to be vigilant,
not to be bystanders,
but to speak out if they encounter bad things
or evil things.
This is exactly what's happened:
The Germans stood by and did nothing
So that is the warning:
and sometimes enthusiastic supporters of Hitler.
Constant vigilance.